i caught one of the dumbest scams ever
and no no no hold your applause it
didn't exactly take a genius to figure
out they advertise a 383 000
return per year they call themselves
seifu as in your money is safe and if
you ask how
fu on their website they say if you
deposit a thousand dollars you could
earn 3.8 million dollars by the end of
the year that is if everything goes
according to plan anyways normally i
would kind of avoid talking about stuff
like this because this kind of scheme is
beneath most people's iq but that all
changed for a couple of reasons one the
project has a market cap of 100 million
dollars so there are a lot of investors
two i talked to one of these investors
who i first knew through safe moon and
now he works as an admin for safe foo
and when talking to him he said
something that concerned me and
convinced me that i needed to
investigate this see if you could spot
it uh can i ask um are you planning on
making a uh a video because like i would
appreciate it if you would like let it
play out what if play letting it play
out is everyone getting rocked what do
you think about that that would be
pretty damn unfortunate yeah and i
totally agree with that but that's not
the the plan here
now this is the mother of all red flags
let it play out sort of the rallying cry
for theranos nicola and every scammer
ever and this is what changed my casual
interest in this ponzi coin into a
full-blown investigation so without
further ado let's investigate seifu to
understand seifu you first must
understand the founder he's a man named
brian legend which sort of sounds like
the name of a bad wrestlemania villain
but is actually brian's second last name
he changed it after being accused of
multiple scams the most notable ones
fitrova tags exchange and clever defy in
each case he's managed to convince
people to give him lots of money many
people lose their money and brian
scurries off to his next project the
most recent being seifu now brian is a
humble man so he doesn't like the term
serial scammer and much prefers low-key
titles like legend visionary
entrepreneur influencer and investor and
he says his accusers of the past are
misunderstanding him those weren't rug
pulls they were just failed businesses
so there's a difference between a
rugball which is a scam and a failed
business they're just two separate
things now as you hear brian almost
sounds credible when you first hear him
he sounds sheepish about the fact that
oh i just i didn't know a lot about
business i didn't have the business
acumen for this so that didn't work out
unfortunately um yeah it just failed
miserably because i didn't have the the
business acumen and to be able to deal
with the fad that was in place he
emphasizes look i'm transparent about my
past i don't have anything to hide i'm
always transparent and i'm happy to
answer any question like it's no secret
right to what happened so i'm yeah i'm
happy to be public about it that's
that's fine this is why it was strange
when i asked him for an interview he
said he only would under the condition
that we not talk about his failed
projects and had to instead only talk
about seifu i thought this was strange
so i dug deeper and it turns out his
projects did not simply fail because he
was a bad businessman but instead they
were rug pulled and followed a pattern
similar to sefu for example his project
clever defy was advertised as being
unruggable in the faq why because the
money was supposed to be safely locked
up in the lp quote under a time lock
mechanism that will allow access to keys
only after 12 months in reality after
one month money was being stolen out of
the project under the function remove
liquidity and i asked brian about this
and he dodged the question instead he
just asked me if i thought he would
enjoy prison now i thought this was a
pretty strange response and back when he
was actually running the scam he gave a
different answer he admitted money had
been taken out but said quote it is
correct analysis and then said don't
worry it is not a negative a portion of
lp was reallocated for funding he said
this quote lp will be re-added and that
people should be strong and huddle which
is very similar to what safe moon said
and in both cases was not true
this lp would not be re-added and once
again directly contradicts what brian
said was possible with the lp he said
all added liquidity will be locked
without key access and clever defy
wasn't the only scam there's also
fetrova which is a fitness blockchain
coin which brian said had partnerships
with people like anytime fitness planet
fitness and more they said so on their
website when these gyms were approached
about this partnership they said it was
a lie quote i received your email we're
not partners with vetrova we're not
associated with vetrova and are working
with our lawyers to take our names off
their website fitness first is not
connected with fetrova now this token
would also tank but before it did it was
listed on brian's new crypto exchange
called the tags exchange later it would
be delisted from it on october 5th
citing a quote high security risk so
you're hearing that right brian's
exchange delisted brian's token for
being a high risk and futrova ended as a
disaster but now that he had a new grift
going brian moved to this tax exchange
where he promised people low fees and
said his exchange had more volume than
even binance
namely tax exchange when i created that
we ran for a good part of a year and we
were really successful we're actually
doing a lot more volume than finance at
that time um and and the reason we were
is because our fees were literally next
to nothing like we were making just
bugger roll like literally no profit
which is kind of like free trading fees
i suppose now brian claims he was
basically making bugger all with his
crypto exchange but as is a pattern with
brian that is not true in fact people
began reporting that they were not able
to withdraw their money from his
exchange brian would later shut it down
claiming it was a business failure that
he was making no money from it in
reality it appears that he was being
chased by accusations of fraud now this
has all been a preamble to bring us to
the main story seifu when i first
confronted brian about his sketchy past
i found it interesting that brian
appeared to have been a fan of me and he
said he liked my safe moon investigation
but didn't like the fact that i was now
investigating him but these dodges
aren't going to work because now that we
have a baseline for brian's past we're
going to talk about sefu and the many
problems with it starting with this
outrageous apy i'm not gonna spend a
long time with why this is so dumb and
absurd i think actually showing you is
better this is a call with one of their
investors so that should mean that your
money at the end of the year
if everything goes according to plan
um
will be worth millions you'll be a
millionaire after putting in
two thousand dollars
that's the hope now obviously that
should be all you really need to see but
of course there are more red flags our
second red flag is the burn wallet which
brian calls the fire pit now burning
tokens is a common strategy in crypto
and how it normally works is that you
send tokens to a dead wallet that no one
has access to so that the supply is
reduced however when brian chose a
wallet to burn to he didn't pick the
normal one that everyone uses but rather
used a wallet that he created and has
access to which goes against
every single premise of a burn wall but
you should know according to him he
pinky promises that he doesn't have
access to this thing the fire pit wallet
and there's obviously being asked a few
times um if we do have
keys to the wallet so if you've got
access to the wallet the answer is no
categorically no 100 no it's impossible
to access we never had the keys to the
fire pit wallet in the first place when
we created the wallet we've done that on
my ether wallet so yes we created it um
and
those and we created with a key store
file which means you can download the
keystore file with a password to access
it we never downloaded it that file was
deleted so that means that we can't have
access to it now i don't know about you
but this sounds all a little hard to
believe and it's very reminiscent of his
clever defy token where the keys were
untouchable right up until they weren't
just so you know this fire pit wallet
has 32 million dollars of sefu in it
right now but we're supposed to believe
the keystore file was deleted now i know
many of you are thinking how could
anyone fall for this well as usual brian
had an explanation for all this he told
his followers he had to do it this way
now there's we can't access it and the
reason why it was created that way is
because we can't
have a auto compounding feature on a
dead address it needs to be a normal
wallet in order to have that compounding
feature so that's the reason so please
don't think we can access the wallet
because no that's not the way the
protocol was designed
it's just it's a it's a limitation of
the blockchain to have to have that
wallet like a normal wallet enable to
get that compounding feature that's all
it's a blockchain limitation it's not an
idea of mine or anybody else is just
that's what needs to happen now it
probably won't surprise you guys but
this is not correct it turns out it was
an idea of brian's and it's not a
limitation of the blockchain at all he
could have done it with a dead wallet a
fact that even his own admins confirm so
this live burn wallet created by
brian legend he said that the reason he
created it that way was the wallet had
to be live you couldn't actually create
it if it you can't rebase it if it's
dead and the question is is that true
um it has come out that that is not true
so the question is who believes this
stuff i mean the guy literally set up a
burn wallet that he controls that has 32
million dollars in it and the community
is just supposed to believe that he
deleted his password it's so absurd that
again like this is why it was kind of i
didn't want to cover it at first i was
like nobody's going to fall for this
stuff but after talking to investors it
it gets a lot worse this guy says that
it's all about trust
he created the wallet but he didn't
download the keystore file
do you know how easy it would be to lie
about something like that
yeah it would be extremely easy um
there's no doubt about it it just boils
down to trust now this investor into
seifu who's also a admin should really
know better than trusting people blindly
it came out that he had invested in both
safe moon and piggy tokens decisions he
now admits were mistakes
oh trust me
i know and i will never involve myself
into a sketchy shady project and
i i realize you know from an outside
perspective you do a lot of
investigations into a safe moon but know
this
i got i got pretty hard with safe moon
then i got again with piggy bank
so
why are you involved in safe food then
as i've done my research and it's a
legitimate project wow well there you go
that's the mentality of these scams no
matter how much evidence no matter how
obvious the fraud or if they've been
through frauds before sometimes holders
will believe right up until the very end
that this project is different even now
brian is trying to spin the narrative
with his followers saying that the
reason he won't respond to my very basic
questions are that i have quote offended
him by using the words shady dealings
and that that's why he blocked me not
because he couldn't answer questions
about his previous scams now as for the
future of sefu i predict that it will
continue to make money as long as they
can find more suckers however all
ponzi-like schemes do come to an end and
this one will be no different brian will
abscond with millions of dollars while
most of his followers end up with little
to nothing and he will move on citing
seifu as yet another business in his
past that failed for seemingly no reason
thanks for watching pump the stock and
i'll see you in the next one